oui on s'en réjouit oui je vous dire
pour une raison simple c'est que
derrière ce nom de Bernard Arnault oui
tous ceux qui ont changé d'être à la
tête d'une grande entreprise
capitalistique c'est qu'il y a des
centaines de milliers d'emplois à la clé
vous voyez moi je vais prendre les
choses très simplement dans ma
circonscription je suis heureux parce
que vous voyez je suis en Eure-et-Loire
donc en région Centre et bal de Loire
qu'est-ce qui est en région Centre-Val
de Loire c'est là où est né la
cosmétique vallée la cosmétique vallée
elle est connue dans le monde entier
c'est un cluster qui est devenu un pôle
de compétitivité mondiale et bien dans
une petite commune de 400 habitants et
200 emplois qui se créent vous voyez ça
c'est bon pour le développement durable
c'est habite à des gens d'aller à Paris
tous les jours travailler ils ont 200
amples sur place et est-ce qu'ils sont
bien payés ou pas c'est ça que pour
garder et bien est-ce que vous avez
souvent vu des gens qui travaillent chez
le BM images direction mal payés mais
très rarement vous en connaissez moi
j'en connais beaucoup qui vous
montreront le contraire à quelques
petites dizaines de kilomètres de chez
moi c'est Vendôme là c'est Bernard
Arnault qui vient d'estime d'investir
une somme considérable donc lorsque vous
connaissez Charles lorsque vous
connaissez la région Centre si vous
connaissez la France et moi je me
réjouis du fait que on soit capable
d'avoir des pépites industrielles et
qu'on soit capable justement de faire en
sorte que derrière il y a des milliers
et des centaines de milliers plutôt que
d'avoir des entreprises délocalisées en
chinois ailleurs bon mais la question la
question finalement sur le chiffre en
lui-même parce que 200 milliards
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que il y a 5 ans il
était à 70 milliards est-ce qu'on va
leur vouloir parce qu'ils ont fait des
bonnes affaires non mais
Clermont-Ferrand il y a quoi il y a
Michelin comment a commencé Michelin il
y a un peu plus d'un siècle c'est une
entreprise qui est un rayonnement
mondial est-ce que salarié sont
maltraités c'est pas vrai ne sont pas
mal traités ce qui est important après
c'est une certaine redistribution de la
richesse ça c'est un autre sujet voilà
ça c'est la politique salariale ça ce
sont d'autres éléments qu'il faut
rentrer en ligne de compte mais je vous
en supplie c'est vrai qu'il y a
intéressement participation dans ces
entreprises dans ces entreprises il y a
une redistribution mieux qu'ailleurs
parce que en effet il y a un lien il y a
un lien ces grandes fortunes là et la
situation des travailleurs qui se
dégradent la précarité les basses à
l'air les conditions de travail il y a
un lien donc moi je me battrai toujours
pour pour dire bah ça suffit de la
défense des salariés nous avons
également le monopole de les aider de
encourager pour les conditions de
travail non ce n'est pas votre propriété
privée non pas du tout mais c'est là où
vous voulez
pas loyers
de faire la même chose ou alors ça ne
marche pas allez donc non mais
oui donc je suis désolé
il n'y a pas de redescription il y a un
sujet sur lequel on peut se retrouver
c'est d'améliorer les conditions de
travail il y a un sujet sur lequel on
peut se retrouver c'est justement des
meilleurs salaires des dividendes de
faire en sorte qu'on soit capable
justement du milieu associé les salariés
à la redistribution ça oui qu'il faille
progresser oui d'ailleurs ce qu'il fait
partie de notre démarche solidarité
Jean-Jacques Bourdin à côté et ceux qui
défendent pas les salariés
pas pardonnez-moi je n'ai pas vrai moi
j'ai été chez l'entreprise également
dans ma vie je pense pas qu'ils étaient
mal payés et je pense que j'ai
accompagné pour le condition de travail
Jean-Philippe dels voilà mais vous ne
répondez pas à ma question n'y a-t-il
pas une injustice vous dites qu'il y a
pas d'injustice moi je dis il y a un
justice qu'en pensez-vous moi je trouve
que oui
parce qu'en fait on s'aperçoit les
crises moi je vous dis très simplement
les choses ma circonscription dans ma
période pour adacha non on m'a pas
beaucoup parlé des retraites on n'a pas
eu le poids de chasse comment je vous
mets le mangez
le coût de la vie qui explose et ça il
faut le reconnaître c'est un vrai sujet
pour savoir important à l'Assemblée avec
Jean-Paul Mathilde prise dans le groupe
sur le partage de la valeur d'ailleurs
ce que il y a eu des supers dividendes
et pour reconnaître que dans cette crise
de l'énergie qu'on la connaît mais dans
l'alimentaire aussi madame marteau il y
a des entreprises qui se sont enrichies
de façon pour moi excessive et avec
quelque part un niveau d'indécence
d'ailleurs permet de vous rappeler que
les petits gouvernementaux vous savez
des différents boucliers qu'on a en
place on va quand même taxer une partie
de ces entreprises il y a un sujet
majeur c'est que le travail il faut
mieux le rémunérer au fait ce débat sur
le partage de la valeur il est
transversal sur les familles politiques
et sur tous les courants de pensée parce
que il y a des montages financiers qui
existent sur les ultra-riches et grâce à
certains montages financiers on dirait
pas le contraire ils sont beaucoup plus
protégés que nous sont le petit artisan
du coin
l'optimisation fiscale je suis d'accord
avec vous à l'optimisation fiscale qui
est beaucoup plus facile pour des très
grands groupes c'est la vérité on peut
pas dire le contraire autant je dis
qu'il faut avoir ces grands groupes qui
réussissent de manière à pouvoir
réinjecter rien industrialiser parce que
vous voyez qu'il y a beaucoup énormément
souffert et donc je m'aperçois quand
même que heureusement que certaines
entreprises sont là pour investir pour
autant l'optimisation fiscale on doit
plus la corriger dans ce pays oui
l'image plus la corriger le perron de
Matignon nous avons tous les syndicats
Unis qui disent qui disent que
ben que la décision de la première
ministre est grave en fait c'est pas
très bon pour le gouvernement cette
image là non c'est un moment très
difficile pour le pays est-ce que le
pays attendait est-ce que le
gouvernement est pas en train de d'unir
à nouveau le front du refus si je puis
dire je fais partie de ceux qui
nourrissaient l'espoir que ce matin
peut-être parmiait d'une médiation telle
qu'on l'avait proposé la semaine
dernière on puisse remettre tout le
monde autour de la table
cette réforme elle est pourtant
indispensable pour le pays il fait
intervenir madame sur les preuves de
pénibilité parce que voyons bien de
parler d'argent là tout à l'heure oui il
y a 30 milliards d'euros de déficit de
structurels de retraite chaque année 30
milliards ça personne n'en parle c'est
vrai et oui mais c'est vrai que la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il y aura moins
d'actif alors après moi je vous dis les
choses très simplement bien sûr il y a
des gens qui me font pas la 64 ans
d'abord la réforme c'est pas tout le
monde à 64 ans c'est si français sur
disent que sont concernés 6 sur 10 donc
déjà 4 sur 10 et j'ai pas tout cela
même ceux qui ont droit à des carrières
longues
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux vous dire que
personne n'ira tout le monde n'ira pas
64 ans simplement sur 10 pour tout le
monde oui madame mais c'est pas nouveau
je vous rappelle que il y a une réforme
de Madame Touraine et de réforme de
Monsieur verse pourquoi on fait cela
aussi parce qu'on a un problème
financier vous le savez très bien il y a
des petites retraites vous dénoncez
également les petites retraités existent
dans ce pays voyez j'ai une vieille
maman je peux vous dire exactement ce
qu'elle a par mois et donc les petites
retraites à 1000 euros à 1100 euros
elles sont là elles existent
mais tout le monde parle que des 64 ans
mais on parle pas des petites retraites
on parle pas non plus on parle de moi le
gouvernement dans très mal parlé
pardon
que tout le monde allait toucher je
crois qu'il fait partie de ces voies de
la majorité comme je l'ai dit et je le
répète on était très communication
deuxième sujet que je regrette c'est
qu'on se met pas autour de la table
parce que le sujet la pénibilité que
vous avez évoqué a juste titre il y a
des métiers extrêmement difficiles pour
lesquels on sait qu'ils ne pourront pas
arriver à 64 ans c'est là où pour moi ça
n'est pas au parlementaire ça n'est pas
au gouvernement décidé cette partenaire
se sous la définir les véritables qui
font que oui celui qui devait partir à
64 ans avec une retraite à taux plein
peut-être partira-t-il demain à 72
j'aurais juste un élément important qui
connaissait sous les radars de la
réforme
en plus je suis l'auteur de cet
amendement d'une clause du revoyure de
la référence en 2027 je sais cette
clause de revoyure c'est une photo pour
voir où on en est comment ça se passe
est-ce que l'emploi des seniors on va le
laisser dans ce pays comme il était un
gâchis humain considérable un Français
sur trois des plus de 60 ans de travail
tous les autres on n'a pas de vous vous
servez à rien c'est Pôle emploi mais
pourquoi et bien voilà et pourquoi
pourquoi
c'est pas faux
ça leur coûte cher parce qu'ils ont de
l'ancienneté donc voilà c'est la
rentabilité et le système il est guidé à
la rentabilité terminée j'ai une
question de à vous poser et ensuite
Seigneur
peut-être faut-il travailler que trois
semaines ou quatre jours par semaine et
former un jeune alors que c'est un
gâchis humain considérable donc
justement c'était tout cela sur lesquels
on doit travailler qui arrive il faut
mettre tout autour de la table et moi ce
que je regrette on uniquement
ne restons pas bloqué dans ce pays alors
vous dites vous dites contre la réforme
alors
j'ai deux questions à poser à
Philippeville respecter le mien
vous souhaitez que tout le monde se
mette autour d'un jour vous le réclamez
oui mais aujourd'hui c'est impossible
vous avez d'un côté la première ministre
le gouvernement le président de la
République ils disent on ne reviendra
pas sur les 64 ans et vous avez de
l'autre côté les syndicats qui disent si
vous ne revenez pas sur les 64 ans nous
ne mettons pas autour de la table alors
que faites-vous que proposez-vous vous
êtes membre de la majorité je vous dis
vous trouvez une médiation préparer d'un
côté de la rivière
qui proposait cela
ont proposé vous l'avez proposé nommé un
médiateur aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
rester figé parce que les salariés ça
serait une solution de sortie peut-être
il y avait peut-être aussi une autre
solution on avait engagé nos retraites
par point qui était peut-être une bonne
réforme et qu'on a oublié et que le
Président de la République a totalement
oublié c'est même pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs mais on reste dans la rue il
ne sait jamais expliqué d'ailleurs vous
avez une explication non parce que
d'abord le système de retraite c'est
extrêmement compliqué oui très compliqué
c'est même quand vous connaissez un peu
le sujet vous en connaissez que le
dixième pour avoir l'humilité
Directoire et des financements
dérogatures de l'État enfin bref là où
je retrouve monsieur del Sol c'est que
naturellement et je vous dis madame
marteau moi je suis attaché au régime
par répartition
et ma famille poétique a même proposé
d'ailleurs des financements annexes soit
en cotisant en plus par exemple pour les
patrons soit en allant chercher
peut-être au travers de la flat taxe
donc l'imposition des ressources
complémentaires mais en l'espèce à leurs
résultats que tu as des choses du fait
même qu'il y aura moins d'actifs il faut
bien que l'on s'en sorte il faut bien
qu'on apporte des retraites d'essence
mais moi je suis un territoire rural où
les gens ne sont pas riche que vous êtes
sensibles à ce mot-là et l'envoient des
SOS est-ce qu'il risque de se passer
c'est qu'il y aura des systèmes du
capitalisation qui vont se développer et
qui vont se renforcer bien sûr dans les
prochaines années et c'est ça la
difficulté et donc il faut vraiment que
l'on en sorte c'est pour ça que te dire
mais tout n'est pas bouclé tu t'en fous
et au contraire les les voies du
dialogue elles font qu'il faut les
renforcer sur les régions spéciaux
pardonnez-moi on a mis la règle du
grand-père la règle du grand-père vous
la connaissez comme moi c'est-à-dire que
celui qui a 25 ans à l'heure actuelle il
a le régime spécial qui est assuré pour
toute sa vie mais est-ce que c'est juste
un chauffeur de bus à Paris travaille 10
ans moins que chez moi dans mon
département c'est totalement injuste
est-ce que les connaissances sont plus
pénibles non là vous défendez défendre
comme j'ai assisté à l'assemblée
nationale la défense du système de la
Banque de France pardonnez-moi non mais
vraiment c'est un système un régime
spécial qui évidemment qui a un siècle
et demi d'existence mais dans la ville
les choses elles sont en capacité
d'évoluer et on peut pas justement comme
cela faire en sorte que vous qui êtes
attentif au plus faible mais les plus
faible malheureusement ne sont pas
suffisamment empoisonnées d'une
différence avec vous je ne suis pas
d'accord je vais vous dire pourquoi vous
avez le droit
parce que quand vous baissez les
cotisations vous diminuez par définition
le budget
de la sécurité sociale et l'ensemble
vous faites quoi vous donnez du pouvoir
d'achat retraité on est d'accord on
parle pas que du poème du but moi
j'aurais parlé du partage de la valeur
Oui la valeur capitale du travail je
pense que l'équilibre des plus assuré à
l'heure actuelle oui là-dessus il y a un
vrai travail transversal qui se fait à
l'Assemblée nous portons en tout cas
nous les centrices que nous sommes
attachés à cela la feuille de paye doit
être mieux rémunérée vous soyez à la
retraite vous soyez au travail et cette
paille mieux rémunérer c'est pas le
salaire direct et par le salaire
indirect c'est ça que je crois beaucoup
à cette intéressement à cette
participation mais c'est pas nouveau
c'est un débat dans le pays qu'on a
depuis des morts mais oui mais justement
là dessus nous avons pas fait le chemin
que nous aurions dû accomplir le sujet
du poids d'achat est un sujet absolument
magnifique
lorsque vous avez des entreprises qui
par exemple ont eu des explosions de
dividendes ces dernières années elle
devrait être plus taxer c'est pour ça
que nous proposons une taxation sur le
super dividendes de manière à ce que si
par exemple vous avez une explosion qui
est ou lorsque cette augmentation de
plus de 20% par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu sur la médiane des deux ou trois
dernières années c'est quelque part il y
a eu un et les profits de la crise et
ceux qui profite de la crypte pour
l'énergie évidemment d'autres domaines
vous savez moi je pense on n'a pas tout
à l'heure parlé des petits industriels
j'ai plein d'industriels qui m'ont
sensibilisé des boulangers des artisans
qui m'ont dit voilà ma facture elle
passe devant 60 000 € comment je fais
comment je fais je suis même allé un
jour dans un village de ma
circonscription voir avec le boulanger
comme on a les calculer le prix de la
baguette voir s'il était acceptable par
l'usager parce qu'il était devant un mur
le mur de l'énergie mais aujourd'hui
c'est l'énergie demain ce sont les
matières premières regarder sur les
marchés publics on voit que tout pour
rien d'exploser notamment en matière de
construction du bâtiment travaux publics
donc ce partage de la valeur c'est un
sujet qu'on ne peut plus écarter la
rémunération du capital ne peut pas être
au même niveau que la rémunération du
travail il y a un sujet peut-être
d'ailleurs passé par là avant d'engager
dans la forme des retraites entre nous
Jean-Jacques Bourdin on pouvait faire en
tout cas en même temps pardonnez-moi
au lieu de ce
formaliser totalement formaliser
totalement et de se concentrer
uniquement sur cette réforme des
retraites parce qu'on a commis l'erreur
c'est d'avoir
plein de dispositifs plein de boucliers
mais ses amis la dupette les insoumis et
le rassemblement national il n'a pas un
cabotier tous les dispositifs on a mis
plein d'outils savez-vous combien on a
injecté
des salaires sur les prix c'est le
minimum c'est la base vos amis politique
n'ont jamais voté le moins des
dispositifs que nous avons mis en place
depuis plusieurs années politique
qui a refusé qui a expliqué qu'il ne
fallait pas indexerce sur les Français
il y a pas de bouclier est arrivé pour
les Français à 10%
[Musique]